vote for us
he led his party to a landslide election
victory in 2019
but boris johnson was to be undone both
by events in which he conspired and also
by his own character flaws that critics
say made him unfit for high office boris
johnson has no social vision he has
there is no moral leadership but for him
it was always about becoming prime
minister not about being prime minister
and he i think he knows himself well
enough that he knows that he does not
have the skills that you need to be a
successful prime minister
sonia pernell was a reporter working
alongside johnson in the brussels bureau
of the daily telegraph she describes a
man with a lot of the child in him who
enjoyed getting into and out of scrapes
a man drawn to chaos and the chaos means
that he can sort of emerge through all
these things going wrong all these all
this noise all this
commotion as the person with the great
idea or the wit the witticism
and that is what appeals to him
for boris johnson the coronavirus
pandemic was a perfect storm of crises
and chaos that blew attention away from
other problems
despite his promise to get brexit done
britain remains mired in dispute with
its biggest trading partner the european
union
the economy is underperforming the cost
of living rising health and education
systems faltering
success with the vaccine program helped
obscure johnson's own indecision and
delays in following scientific advice
that contributed to one of the highest
death tolls in the developed world
former chief advisor dominic cummings
described the prime minister's
leadership as erratic indecisive
distracted nobody
could find a way around the problem of
the prime minister just like a shopping
trolley smashing from one side of the
aisle into the other
the shopping trolley metaphor would
quickly be seized upon by the opposition
so he's doing what he always does
crashing over to the other side of the
aisle boris johnson learned early to be
self-sufficient in a family of
competitive siblings with a mother who
suffered ill health and a father who was
frequently absent
at the elite british boarding school
eaton he came to believe ordinary rules
did not apply to him in the infamous
bullingdon drinking club at oxford the
outward persona of a jovial buffoon
disguised an inner ambition for power
and as both a journalist for the times
newspaper and a minister in opposition
johnson was accused of lying and fired
these then were the qualities he brought
to politics as mayor of london as
foreign secretary and then as prime
minister
entitlement dishonesty and indifference
this is really the first time in his
life uh where he's ever actually been
held to account for anything he's always
been indulged he's always been excused
there's always been reasons made for him
for his bad behavior
there was wide support for his handling
of the war in ukraine but johnson never
recovered from the scandal known as
partygate he received a police fine for
attending a lockdown party in downing
street making him the first british
prime minister to break the law while in
office
a civil service report into a string of
similar gatherings described a failure
of leadership
eventually 148 of his own mps 40 percent
of the parliamentary party turned
against him in a vote of no confidence
boris johnson limped on for a bit
but the reasons to forgive him had run
out jonah al jazeera
let's cross to paul brennan he's joining
us from london so you were at the
announcement that was made by boris
johnson paul talk us through the
statement and the dramatic moment
well the downfall of a prime minister
anywhere i think is always one of a
momentous national occasion and and this
was no different the
first indications that we were going to
get a statement where when the
technicians from downing street came out
and started laying cable
along the road behind me and then from a
couple of doors down from downing street
number 10 downing street uh carrie
johnson and a group of downing street
staffers came out
and stood along the top end of the of
the street and then to my left uh from
another direction from the cabinet
office uh to my left uh a group of boris
johnson's most loyal mps uh came out and
stood here at the gates of downing
street at the far end of the street
there was a large group of the general
public along with demonstrators sending
out music through loudspeakers uh and it
really built up for a um a really a
climactic situation finally the lectern
came out into the middle of the street
and very quickly after that boris
johnson emerged he didn't hang around
there was a round of applause by from
his supporters for him but he didn't
stop to acknowledge that he went
straight into st into the speech that he
had prepared for him and and and
delivered it a short sharp uh speech uh
the reaction
uh from among the commentariat that i've
been looking at on social media in the
wake of that speech are that it was you
know devoid of any self-reflection
frankly there's uh a lot more he could
have said about this short his own
personal shortcomings that have brought
us uh to this uh stage he talks about
the
the decision of the conservative mps to
ask him eccentric which rather suggests
that he thinks they've lost their minds
um that said though there are many
people who will not be mourning the loss
of boris johnson and not least of them
is kirsten who is the labour opposition
leader let's hear
him he needs to go he can't cling on in
this way his own party have finally
concluded that he's unfit to be prime
minister they can't now inflicting on
the country for the next few months it's
obvious he's unfit to be prime minister
that's been blindingly obvious for a
very very long time and if they don't
get rid of him then labor will step up
in the national interest and bring a
vote of no confidence because we can't
go on with this prime minister clinging
on for months and months to come
paul he is staying on for a little bit
longer though what do we know uh is
going to happen in terms of a timetable
and how quickly uh he might be replaced
yeah i mean
that that uh interview with uh kirsten
was recorded before boris johnson's
actual speech was um was given here so
uh the last part uh
overtaken by events i think but the
actual timetable now uh for for the uh
departure of boris johnson is still up
in the air somewhat i mean
the prime minister of britain is not
elected by a general election um the
party takes power through a general
election and then the prime minister is
elected by the members of parliament of
the biggest party from that general
election so it's down to the
conservative party in parliament uh to
uh make the process uh work now
the 1922 committee is the backbench
committee which uh organizes votes of no
confidence for example and it will be
for them
to set the timetable and what we're
looking at most likely is for the
candidates to present themselves and the
expectation is that we could whittle it
down to two leading candidates by the
summer recess which is july the 21st
they could then spend the summer
campaigning amongst the conservative
membership that's around 100 000 members
with a view to holding an election in
the autumn time in time for the annual
conservative party conference um which
is later in the autumn but there are a
lot of misgivings about boris johnson
staying on in downing street while that
process is undertaken dominick cummings
his former closest advisor now his
nemesis since leaving down history he
says that to leave boris johnson here in
downing street could risk risk carnage
and the plenty of other mps who say look
boris johnson was the problem and to
have him
sitting here um overseeing even a kind
of caretaker administration
frankly is not acceptable to them so
there are a lot of questions that are
unanswered still about whether boris
johnson can or will be forced to step
aside so that somebody else can oversee
the transition period through to the
autumn okay thank you so much paul
brennan reporting from london